you can say that it has been a step
change with the internet because never
before not even with sort of printed
media or television has one individual
been able to do mass communication
because before you at least needed the
medium you needed television or access
to radio but today through the internet
one individual can do mass communication
so it means a completely different
scenario also communication wise and I
think we see that today people
communication to me is a tool for
strengthening democracy we are not there
to sell something we are we are decision
makers we are politicians we are it
elected in the European Parliament that
etc in the parliaments you need to make
sure that communication is used to
strengthen democracy to engage better in
in a dialogue with voters and and with
citizens and for the first time you can
do that also very very broadly you can
invite people to comment as we did for
the first time on the new chemicals
legislation reach and we we had more
than 7,000 responses very detailed very
well crafted most of them and and it was
it was amazing to see that that when you
open up that opportunity people also
they want to participate they can they
are capable of it and they are much more
demanding of course they want to be
judged by themselves so it means a
little more of difficulty also for
journalists for example because people
might actually bypass the journalists
and they want to follow a debate
themselves directly online that will
make make up their own minds
he did it masterfully of course I mean
he managed to not only erase money to
his campaign but and this time from
individuals many individuals which made
him less dependent on big donors like
the old industry or what have you
and but he also did it using the the
sort of the social media to organize not
only send a message but sort of organize
events and and mobilize the voters as
well so this was a way to say well we
can meet and have a party there or we
can have a rally that night or we can do
whatever information sharing or
what-have-you so he used it to the full
and and the full potential of not only
sending his political message but also
mobilizing people and I think this is
what we can learn and he did it through
of course a simple message that
everybody could understand I'm not sure
that it would work exactly like that in
Europe but I think we can learn from
from from this to have a simple message
that that people can can understand and
take to their hearts so there are a
number of things where we can definitely
share experience and say that this is
something we could we could do as well
and there are also differences there the
money being being won the money does not
play the same role in European elections
you don't have to do that much of
fundraising for example to be able to be
you